all right all right
happy jobs day everybody
um
it's a it's a good Friday I mean unless
you're long stocks then maybe it's not
such a good Friday but welcome into
Market takes I appreciate you all
joining me I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you're here
with me so I want to say I appreciate
that and thank you for joining us here
on Market takes right here on YouTube I
am Dion rabone reporter at the Wall
Street Journal we are breaking down
diving into and dissecting all things
about today's non-farm payrolls report
for September
um we're gonna talk about the big
takeaways all that good stuff we're
gonna get into all of it from today's
jobs report why it matters what it means
what we're looking for going forward
we're diving into all that so again
thank you for joining us here on Market
takes look today we're going to talk
about obviously what the headline number
was and how that was compared to
expectations talk about the market
reaction look at stocks bonds crypto FX
Commodities all that good stuff we are
going to talk about what the number
means for the economy and very very
importantly what this number likely
means for the Federal Reserve we're
going to talk about what it says for
inflation and we're going to talk about
what the number and what some of the
little pieces in there within the jobs
report tell us about uh you know the
likelihood of recession and last but not
least we're also going to talk about
what to watch for next because obviously
this isn't the end this is you know just
the latest piece of data that we'll get
but important to keep in mind this is
the last jobs report that the Federal
Reserve is going to get before their
meeting in November the fed's November
meeting is November 2nd before the jobs
report comes out on November 4th so this
is the last jobs report they're going to
see before they make that decision uh
during their two-day meeting November
1st and 2nd and we get that report on
November 2nd so this is a big report
um let's get into it let's just dive all
the way in right now no more time
wasting um the report showed 263 000
jobs added last month versus
expectations of 250 five thousand jobs
basically a little bit over or 250 000
jobs a little bit over expectations the
the you know the fact that it was eight
thousand or fifteen thousand or sorry or
eight thousand or thirteen thousand
above expectations doesn't really mean
that much the bigger deals that we are
down from August when we had 315 000
jobs added but not that much just just a
hair down and we know that the Federal
Reserve is looking for the labor market
to cool down we're going to talk about
all of that in just a second so slightly
stronger than expectations on the job
report as we've seen from the market
maybe not slightly better than expected
which is usually what you say when you
add more jobs than economists had
predicted but slightly stronger and I'll
get into all that real quick note uh the
Bureau of Labor Statistics did point
this out in their report this morning
hurricane Ian had no discernible effect
that's a quote on the employment and
unemployment data for September
basically that hurricane made landfall
after the unemployment data had been
collected you know researchers there
saying this didn't reduce or increase
that's not something that folks need to
be worried about with this report
definitely something to watch for in the
October report when we get that in
November but right now hurricane Ian the
devastation down there in the Southeast
Florida South Carolina and that region
did not affect the jobs report numbers
for this month so that's not something
you need to take with a grain of salt so
look let's talk about the big elephant
in the room that's the Federal Reserve
we know the FED wants the job market and
the labor market to cool down to kind of
slow from this Torrid pace of hiring
that we've seen now why is that well in
the fed's eyes we've got unemployment
greeting down to low levels below
historical norms and that's giving a lot
of pressure on wages which is going to
keep prices elevated if folks have more
money if they've got more power to
demand raises to increase their salaries
they're going to keep buying keep
spending and that's going to keep prices
going up this is a you know it's a
vicious cycle where you know prices rise
but if folks can keep paying those
higher prices well the prices will just
keep on Rising now the idea is the Fed
kind of wants consumers to tap out
really just say okay you know what
things are getting too expensive I can't
afford this I'm gonna stop buying these
things stop buying those things as
companies see they're sales reduced they
start to cut prices because they say oh
man we can't just keep raising prices
like this no one can afford it and
that's what brings inflation down now
that's at least you know kind of how
we've heard it explained by fed share
Jerome pal and some other folks on the
Federal Reserve talking about why they
want the job and labor market to cool
down now some economists disagree they
say hey look Americans on the labor
front have lost so much negotiating
power have lost so much power to demand
higher wages even as prices for things
like College medical care housing and
all that have really just spiked and
skyrocketed out of control folks uh
their jobs and their salaries have not
kept up this is a good thing that
Americans are finally starting to catch
up and you guys destroying that labor
market that strength in the labor market
is going to do more harm than good we're
seeing more and more economists start to
come out with kind of that view and
we've seen some big organizations start
to say hey maybe you guys are doing too
much we're going to talk about that a
little later the most important piece of
this report I think really if you're
going to talk about a big takeaway is
that we saw payrolls grow by an average
of more than 440 000 jobs during the
first half of this year that is a huge
number historically 440 000 jobs average
per month uh over the first six months
of the year over the first half of this
year locked in now after these revisions
and after this report through September
so that's a big number much higher than
average and suggests that you know this
labor market is really not cooling down
as the Federal Reserve has said they
would like to I'm going to read you a
quote from an economist Tom Simons at
Jeffrey's he says quote there is not a
lot out of capacity for the labor force
to grow and the strong wage pressure is
going to continue to be an issue we
still expect another 75 basis point rate
hike in November from the Federal
Reserve a lot of fed speakers have come
out over the past week or so and really
kind of said you know we have a lot more
to do to slow down inflation we saw that
CPI report earlier this month for uh for
I'm sorry earlier last month we saw it
for August which said that inflation is
still rising at 8.3 percent year over
year even though it is slowing down
month over month so the fed's still
worried about inflation and you know
clearly this report has not done a lot
or really anything to assuage that worry
or to make them say hey you know what
okay this is finally having an effect
now we might want to slow down and and
that's probably the big takeaway so
let's actually let's let's step out and
let's hear from or look into the market
I'm logging into wsj.com right now we've
got the market finally open right now
and we are seeing kind of across the
board stocks down like I said if your
long stocks today's jobs report probably
didn't make you very happy you've got
the Dow s p Nasdaq all down by more than
a percent uh the NASDAQ actually down by
1.8 percent down almost two percent so
watch out for that we might see another
day of a lot of red on the market after
we started the fourth quarter you know
the beginning of October was really
strong you saw stocks bouncing higher
led by some of those high-flying tech
stocks and growth stocks it looks like
we're seeing a reversal of that after
this job support that really just locked
in the fact that the FED has the cover
that they need to continue being
aggressive maybe another and likely it
seems as far as the Market's concerned
another 75 basis point rate hike for the
FED at its next meeting in November
based on what we saw from this report
the one of the more interesting pieces
of the market that I was looking at was
the bond market you guys know if you
follow me I love bonds baby bonds is
where it's at the the treasury market
spiked up really across the board kind
of rising at you know the longer dated
the shorter dated even in the middle all
by around six basis points so you're
seeing those longer dated yields pick up
that means expectations for more
inflation but also for more growth so
those recession worries that have really
been bringing yields down at the longer
end of the curve 10 years 20 years 30
years
that's kind of being priced out after
this jobs report because there still
looks like there's strength in the
economy employers are still hiring wages
are still Rising not that fast not as
fast as overall inflation but wages are
still rising and the likelihood of a
recession it looks like the market right
now at least in response to this jobs
report is lowering those expectations we
had seen the two-year yield which is
most responsible or most responsive
excuse me to those expectations for the
Federal Reserve rate hikes really tick
up and and jump higher than the rest of
the overall yield curve that Rose to
4.33 earlier today it's come back a
little bit from that but towering over
yields for 10 year and 30 years uh the
30-year bond is at 3.85 percent the 10
years at 3.89 so again you're looking at
about 30 35 40 basis points of
difference between the two-year it's
higher by about 40 basis points than the
10-year and the 30-year that suggests
you know again worries that the Federal
Reserve is going to keep raising keeping
aggressive while that economic growth is
not going to do as much but today's
report suggests that those worries are
have been lessened just a little bit it
looks like the labor market and the
economy are stronger we look at across
the markets you're seeing the dollar A
Little Bit Stronger there you're seeing
some weakness in the Yen the Euro and
overall currencies versus the dollar
that was taking up just a little bit but
remember we are at some of those
all-time highs that we reached or we're
near those levels of all-time highs that
we reach in late September the crypto
Market really just selling off
suggesting that yes it's expected the
Federal Reserve is going to do more
we've seen crypto really tied to those
Federal Reserve rate hike expectations
really over the last couple months uh or
longer than the last couple months
really over the course of this year so
we've seen that really the what the
market is telling us today they expect
the Federal Reserve to keep being
aggressive to be locked in to raise
rates probably around 75 basis points
again uh in November or at least 50
basis points which is twice the normal
rate that they've hiked at you know this
Millennium and that is going to continue
to do some damage to a lot of these
markets and potentially to the overall
real economy now the sneaky important
piece of data that I found in this
report in the jobs report today was that
drop in labor force participation we had
a big spike up in labor force
participation in August and you saw
really a lot of folks coming into the
labor force a lot more people coming off
of the sidelines as they say well you
saw a kind of reversal of that point two
percent increase in August
this month really fully reversing and
the number of unemployed people Rose
while the number of people not in the
labor force also Rose so less people in
the labor force less people employed
that's why you saw the drop in the
unemployment rate that's not necessarily
a great thing across the board really
we've seen data deteriorating we've seen
consumer sentiment declining after that
big pickup we'd seen since June uh
purchasers purchasing managers index
basically they talk to businesses House
business is it better is it worse it's
starting to get worse we're starting to
see those numbers contract uh both in
the U.S and globally especially on the
good side on the manufacturing side on
the services side we've seen just the
opposite a real pickup a significant
increase and services make up a lot of
the U.S economy about 60 70 80 percent
depending on which survey you look at
but that's really been a big difference
also pending an existing home sales
pending sales pending home sales this
month we just got the report excuse me
last month when we got the report this
month down 23 percent durable goods
orders have been down various fed
manufacturing surveys across the board
Kansas City Philadelphia when you look
at all those different parts of the
country you're seeing a consistent 10
Trend downward that's what the Federal
Reserve wants they said they're ready to
take us into a recession if that's what
it takes to get inflation down but again
the deterioration of a lot of data but
we did not see that in today's jobs
report so that's why you're saying I
think a lot of the market action that
you are now a lot of these layoffs at
Amazon and Peloton which just came out
today have really taken center stage
also you had the the hiring freeze at
Facebook those who've got a lot of
attention but when we look at this big
picture data about the the us as a whole
today's job support tells us companies
may be slowing their hiring they may be
laying off people a little bit but
they're not we're not seeing big wide
scale layoffs we're not seeing net job
losses we are seeing net job gains
continuing at a large and a pretty fast
pace the Challenger job Cuts report
showed layoffs fell 20 in August that
was the second month in a row of
declines you also had the initial
jobless claims report earlier this
earlier this week showing that jobless
claims Rose to the highest since the
last week of August but still well below
uh the long-term Trend and they just hit
a five-month low last week so layoffs
really have not been a thing we did see
in the jolts report the job opening and
labor turnover survey that the number of
job openings employers had dropped by
over 1.1 million jobs in July but that
seems to be the trend employers are just
doing less hiring not more firing not
more layoffs not cutting hours that's a
good thing for the economy that's a good
thing for the American people you and I
are out there working our jobs but it's
not great when you look at what the
fed's going to do and that's what the
market is responding to and that's
really that tells us a lot about the big
picture and what we can expect moving
for forward now wages are still Rising
by about five percent we saw average
hourly earnings Rise by five percent but
again that's well below the 8.3 percent
pace of inflation that we saw for the
month so you know average hourly
earnings are you know consistently at
that five percent Mark they really come
down from about five and a half percent
earlier this year and last year to that
lower level about five percent and
that's part of why these economists are
saying hey fed uh maybe you should check
out these numbers because earnings and
salaries and wages are not what seems to
be driving inflation right now or an
increase in those things the IMF last
week said a wage price spiral is
unlikely saying that labor costs are not
the main driver of the recent bout of
inflation or rather that wages and
inflation are being pushed up by
separate if also related factors
um you know that's a big thing also the
United Nations the UN coming out and
saying hey fed you're doing a lot of
damage to the global economy all these
other countries out here that have a lot
of debt they've borrowed a lot of money
in dollars the value of the dollar is
getting stronger it's getting higher
that's making the amount they have to
pay back even higher and that's hurting
their economies and we could see a now
the U.N is predicting the IMF is
predicting a global recession uh next
year
and that could be more damaging If the
Fed continues to be aggressive and when
you look at this jobs report today that
likely backs the case for like I said
more aggressive action from the Federal
Reserve uh listen
that that I think is all we're going to
talk about today on the jobs report
front but I know you are going to want
to be here tomorrow sorry not tomorrow
tomorrow Saturday I'm gonna be off I
hope you'll be off as well I know you're
going to want to be here on Saturday
Sunday Monday is the day that I will be
right back here on Market takes we are
going to be looking ahead we've got
producer price index that's the PPI
that's what businesses are paying
business or wholesale inflation that
report is coming out that week Consumer
Price Index CPI that is the big one
that's what the whole Market is watching
these days that's coming out next week
we've got a number of other pieces of
important data I will be breaking all
that down right here on Monday on Market
takes I hope you will be there and won't
be a
that's a square don't do it
um and we'll be breaking all that down
so appreciate you being with me today on
Market takes we will be back doing it
live right here for the Wall Street
Journal uh on Monday and I hope you'll
join me and uh yeah that's gonna do it
for Market takes today I'm Dion rabone
reporter at the Wall Street Journal
thank you so much for